ok peut-être sur la sur la sobriété
effectivement donc
je pense qu'il faut distinguer sobriété
rationnement on est au brier tc faire la
même chose avec moins d'énergie c'est
pas faire moins de choses on verra donc
en tout cas c'est comme ça que je
conçois on a été saisie comme toutes les
entreprises par le gouvernement ont pour
être capable de faire moins 10% par la
sobriété d'ici deux ans on a répondu
qu'on saurait faire
comment on fait il ya le tertiaire et
puis il ya la traction des trains sur le
tertiaire basse et les gestes simples
d'économie un combat auquel on peut tous
penser qu'on peut pousser un peu plus
loin
et ça peut rapporter 1 c'est
l'exemplarité et c'est donc ça on va le
faire bien évidemment on a commencé
c'est aussi peut-être de
l'investissement parce que c'est pour ça
qu'il faut au moins deux ans parce que
tout ce qu'ils ont la scion de bâtiments
ça se fait pas du jour au lendemain donc
à on est tout à fait prêt à accélérer un
plan de notamment sur les bâtiments pour
mieux isoler les bâtiments etc etc donc
si on va le faire et sur l'aspect
conduite on n'est pas dans une logique
de suppressions de trains dans le plan
de sobriété que ce soit très clair je
crois que c'était confirmé par le
ministre il ya eu un peu de confusion
sur le sujet on peut faire l'idée de
ralentir les trains et paris sympathique
mais ça marche pas parce qu'on voiture
chez l'ouest quand on le fait ça mais
que toutes les correspondances en l'air
sur la queue pour bourg po paris dont
imaginez si tous les trains sont en
retard on sait en sort plus dans les
correspondances deuxièmement
l'attractivité du train baisse quand
même donc on doit inciter les gens ne
prend l'avion ou reprendre la voiture et
3 la productivité des moyens aussi parce
que si vous aller plus lentement la
productivité à la fois des matériels
roulants mais aussi des conducteurs
alves passe kim dans le même horaire et
on paie à l'horaire ils font il faut
moins de kilomètres donc pour l'ensemble
des trois facteurs c'est pas une bonne
idée bon je crois que ça a été reconnue
par le gouvernement voilà donc donc on
fait d'éco-conduite on le fait déjà et
on peut aller plus loin plus fort en
veillant à ce que les conducteurs
profite du profil en fait c'est comment
quand ça descend on n'accélère pas on
est vite fait de freiner d'accélérer
inutilement on se sert de ce fameux
cette capacité du train à rouler tout
seul nous allons optimiser au maximum
pour consommer le moins possible et ça
peut rapporter beaucoup ça peut aller
très bon conducteur arrive à gagner 10 à
15 % n'en faut que faut qu'un conducteur
moyen y arrivera ce que le très bon
c'est faire parce que voilà il a de
l'expérience il faut absolument propagez
cette expérience le plus largement
possible parce que tous les conducteurs
soient capables de le faire on avait
aussi des pratiques qui feront qu il
faut considérer à l'époque où les nages
et et pas cher on pouvait laisser à la
res on appelle déco stationnement en
stationnement ont laissé les pentes au
lever pour assurer le chauffage qui mène
sur ma chaîne pendant des heures et des
heures et des heures voire toute la nuit
bon c'est le genre de pratique va
falloir arrêter quitte à faire venir
quelqu'un une heure plus tôt pour une
heure plus tôt roche-aux-fées la ram etc
voilà on a quelques économies accessible
en revoyant nos modes d'organisation et
quand on combine tout ça on doit être on
doit être aux 10% voilà
[Musique]